[Musique]
bienvenue en ce joli mois de mai un rien
venteux paris sac et tv vous propose
d'enfiler vos baskets
on vous emmène à la plaine des sports de
l'université paris saclay la voilà à
doter de deux terrains synthétiques
flambant neuf mais ce n'est pas fini
nous avons assisté à l'inauguration
nous reviendrons aussi sur un marathon
la journée entrepreneuriat étudiant
université paris saclay ça s'est passé à
centrale supélec 200 étudiants sont
venus défendre leur projet à suivre
aussi le programme des paris région
smart weeks des événements dédiés à
l'innovation au numérique et au high
tech sont organisées dans toute la
france
et bien sur votre territoire est
concerné et organise un événement le
paris saclay spring ensuite notre agenda
ce sera la fin de cette émission et vous
verrez on ne s'ennuie pas sur votre
territoire
vous aimez le sport alors chaussez vos
baskets et venez découvrir ces deux
terrains synthétiques flambant neufs de
l'université paris saclay d'autres
équipements sportifs vont suivre nous
sommes à la plaine des sports c'est un
tout nouveau lieu il vient d'être
inauguré
[Musique]
aujourd'hui marque le début d'une
nouvelle aventure
la monture de la pratique sportive de
l'université paris 7 et pour cela nous
allons disposer très prochainement de ce
complexe sportif qui fait une superficie
de 13 hectares avec un bâti d'un hectare
avec quatre terrains de sport une zone
athlétique et qui répondra différentes
missions la première mission c'est
d'être un atout un atout pour la
formation des élèves une deuxième
mission qui relève de la vie de campus
ça va être une composante importante et
essentielle pour les élèves pour les
étudiants et puis quelque part à une
troisième mission qui relève de
l'attractivité
aujourd'hui on se doit de présenter si
on prétend être une université à échelle
mondiale d'avoir des installations
sportives de qualité ça sera je l'espère
est très certainement le cas avec ce
complexe sportif
[Musique]
suit donc le directeur du service des
sports de l'université paris sud
c'est un service commun de l'université
qui doit bien entendu promouvoir une
politique sportive sur l'ensemble des
établissements de paris sud c'est donc
sur trois départements et neuf sites et
nous
nous accueillons bien entendu ces
installations sur le plateau avec grande
joie puisque enfin nous disposons pour
des étudiants et des personnels qui
travaillent sur ce plateau
d'installations sportives de proximité
on sait que la proximité est un élément
essentiel si on souhaite que le plus
grand nombre
pratiquer une activité régulièrement
et donc on se réjouit de ces deux
premiers terrains qui rappelle bien
entendu l'arrivée d'autres terrains
puisque fin novembre prochain seront
livrés si tout se passe bien
les deux terrains de rugby et le
complexe d'athlétisme
et puis pour la rentrée de septembre
2020 donc c'est bientôt le bâti avec de
nombreux gymnase le mur d'escaladé cet
agrès
pour couverts de tennis etc début
d'année on a été convoqué par
l'université de sacrées pour mettre au
point l'inauguration de la plaine des
sports étant responsable l3 management
ayant un projet tutoré d'organisation
d'événements nous avons pris en charge
l'organisation d'événements alors en
concertation avec l'université paris-x
sacré ans il ya eu des réunions vraiment
très régulière mais ce sont 25 étudiants
qui ont travaillé chaque semaine pour
imaginer cet événement avec les
animations et puis une concertation
régulière avec l'université paris-x
sacré de la communication que c'est à la
fois un projet pédagogique qui mobilise
les étudiants et qui envoie la
concrétisation aujourd'hui c'est donc
ici à centrale supélec que s'est
déroulée cette journée entrepreneuriat
étudiant paris saclay un événement qui a
rassemblé 200 étudiants ils sont venus
présenter leur projet à de futurs
investisseurs il y a eu des séances de
pitch mais aussi un salon plus classique
un rendez vous que nous présente
clémentine belle feinte elle est chargée
de mission développement en
entrepreneuriat à l'université paris
saclay
[Musique]
la journée entrepreneuriat étudiant
c'est une journée organisée par
l'université paris saclay est ouverte à
tous les étudiants et jeunes diplômés de
l'université paris saclay qui ont un
projet entrepreneurial
l'objectif c'est de les rassembler au
même endroit pour montrer la richesse et
la diversité de leurs projets auprès
d'investisseurs de starter de grands
mots qui sont là pour découvrir les
start up mais selon ce qu'on demandera à
travers cette journée les étudiants
auront l'occasion de présenter leurs
projets sous différentes formes
la première derrière moi c'est le salon
des étudiants entrepreneurs où chaque
étudiant à un stand où il peut exposer
son projet et se faire challenge et par
l'ensemble des visiteurs de l'événement
en parallèle il y à un concours de peach
ou chaque projet à trois minutes pour
essayer de convaincre un jury composé
d'entrepreneurs d'investisseurs de
grïngo et d'accompagner tard à l'issue
du concours de bitche chaque projet va
gagner un chèque de 500 euros de
l'université paris s'inquiète pour les
aider à continuer l'aventuré et chaque
président du jury a mis à disposition
des projets un cadeau peut donc c'est du
coworking de l'accompagnement une
rencontre qualifiée avec un business
angels ou encore l'accompagnement
aujourd'hui on a différents types de
projets ça va du projet produit dans le
comme par exemple néo ce père
qui est un outil pour les
orthoprothésiste à à un produit pour les
aquariums coco plan qui a un nouveau
produit pour la filtration des périodes
la finalité de cette journée c'est pour
l'ensemble des projets de se faire
connaître de rencontrer des partenaires
de trouver des structures
d'accompagnement et aussi de décoller
grâce aux cadeaux de nos présidents du
jury la journée entrepreneuriat de
l'université paris saclay accueille 70
projets portés par deux centres
étudiants entrepreneurs et accueillent
aujourd'hui 500 visiteurs
[Musique]
la mode à sa fashion week le high tech
et le numérique on les paris région
smart weeks c'est la seconde édition de
cette manifestation qui se déroule dans
toute l'ile-de-france et bien sur votre
territoire
y participent avec un événement inédit
le paris saclay spring tout de suite les
précisions d'alexandra du blanche elle
est vice présidente chargée du
développement économique à la région ile
de france
[Musique]
avec valérie pécresse on veut faire de
la région ile-de-france un hub mondial
de l'innovation et on veut devenir la
première smart régions d'europe et dans
ce cadre là on a décidé d'organiser les
paris serait jane smart weeks donc les
semaines de la région intelligente 2018
qui est toute une série d'événements
tout au long de l'année avec un focus en
mai juin ou notamment on aura
l'événement paris-saclay spring et le
but c'est vraiment de mettre en avant
toutes nos entreprises nos startups et
nos pépites technologiques à la fois
destination des entreprises et mais
aussi du grand public pour qu'il
découvre vraiment tous nos atouts en
termes de filières stratégiques clés
qu'on a identifié à la région tels que
la médecine du futur la cybersécurité la
robotique
l'intelligence artificielle sur lesquels
on travaille déjà énormément par
d'autres dispositifs régionaux ce qui
concerne le public de ces événements il
ya toute une série d'événements donc qui
ont des publics différents il y en a
certains pour grand public mais c'est
plus particulièrement quand même à
destination des entreprises nationales
mais également internationale tout ce
qu'on fait on est dans une politique
d'attractivité la région et on veut
donner à voir au monde entier tous ses
atouts qui sont les nôtres notamment sur
paris saclay on a toute une série
d'événements mais pas que des événements
puisque on soutient également d'autres
projets très structurant pour la région
en termes d'innovation je pense sur
saclay par exemple digi hall qui a
vocation à être un centre vraiment à
vocation internationale sur
l'intelligence artificielle dans ce
cadre là d'ailleurs on a lancé aussi le
premier challenge international sur
l'intelligence artificielle très
récemment qui court jusqu'au 17 juin
on a aussi à paris saclay
d'autres évènements que l'on soutient et
d'autres structures que l'on soutient
tel que l'a dit et factory hub sur la
fabrication 3d est donc vraiment il ya
tout un ensemble d'actions qui crée cet
écosystème très positif et qui a
vocation à faire briller la région au
niveau international et maintenant notre
agenda attention il est chargé
événements autour de l'innovation mais
cette fois à destination des enfants
il s'agit du start up for kids paris
saclay là aussi c'est la première
édition là aussi ça se passe ici à
centrale supélec sang aura lieu les
samedi 26 et 27 mai que tu es entre 6 et
14 ans ou entre 15 et 20 ans ce
programme a été spécialement conçu pour
t'initier en t'amusant donc venez tenter
l'expérience relever le défi participer
au haka ton de l'essonne c'est du 1er au
3 juin au collège juliette adam à gif
sur yvette
en fait le département vous met au défi
vous les startups heures vous les
étudiants mais aussi toutes les
personnes qui ont envie d'imaginer des
solutions innovantes pour le quotidien
des essonniens de demain c'est le haka
ton de l'essonne tenter votre chance
enfin ce numéro vous inviter à chaussez
vos baskets et bien gardez les pour le
tour paris saclay 2018 c'est le dimanche
10 juin rendez-vous au complexe sportif
du moulon à gestion yvette et que vous
soyez sportif confirmé ou simples
pratiquants amateurs de balades en
famille et bien vous trouverez de quoi
satisfaire vos envies
il y a quatre boucles 12 25 40 et 70 le
kilomètre voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv d'ici là
restez informé sur notre site le pap est
ce point fr ou sur tv 78 merci de votre
fidélité
[Musique]